pregnant Kate Middleton and husband  Prince William attend Easter services  with the Queen but where were Meghan  Markel and Prince Harry  [Music]  the royal couple attended Easter service  alongside Queen Elizabeth on Sunday at  st. George's Chapel at Windsor Castle  the same historic church that will house  Harry and Megan's wedding on May 19th  but the pair was nowhere in sight hello  is reporting the lovebirds were most  likely enjoying some downtime out of the  public eye  another noticeably absent royal the  Queen's 96 year old husband Prince  Philip although Philip officially  retired from his public duties at last  fall this is the second public outing in  a week the duke chose not to attend  he was also missing from the traditional  royal Maundy service at st. George's  Chapel last Thursday due to experiencing  problems with his hip  [Music]  [Applause]